[Music]
okay everyone this is my spoiler review
of the new predator prequel pray
this was directed by dan trattenberg and
written by patrick iason it stars amber
mid thunder so
with this film i had low expectations
because i was someone in the camp that
wasn't crazy about 10 cloverfield lane
the previous film that dan trachtenberg
had directed and i was prepping for this
film by re-watching the first predator
to get me kind of in the mindset about
just the lore and everything that comes
with it and i was pleasantly surprised
how great this film was
there was a lot of things i liked about
this film and
what this film did so well was have such
a great idea where it was going to go
from point a to point b and on the way
there everything had a purpose and the
amount of action you got for a film when
you want to see an awesome villain like
predator in it you got that payoff in
the original unique ways that weren't
seen in previous films and it felt fresh
enough but thematically the way we
follow this character of nauru and what
was great about nauru is that she starts
off as someone who is struggling and
she's weak and becomes strong as the
film moves on and becomes what she wants
to be by the end but learns as well and
that it's not exactly what she wanted in
the end but she got it what she needed
in the sense of becoming this
hunter this predator
but in the way her brother had taught
her where it was about not just hunting
to hunt it was hunting to survive and
she does that here by the end protecting
her tribe and getting the big prey which
was the predator but also the best part
of this film was just the line her
talking about what makes her so
dangerous is not being seen as a threat
which was perfectly thematic for the
predator because the predator is so
dangerous because he
sees people as threats he detects them
and to have that is such a skill and
something to embrace for the character
of
nauru was awesome and it works so well
here and even getting to see naoru do
really badass things when she gets these
trappers and actually takes him down a
lot like the predator himself and it was
cool to kind of warm us up to things
where we saw the predator taking out
predator animals that were after their
prey but it would come around full
circle by nauru making the predator her
prey and her becoming a predator i also
love things they showed here about
humanity where it's thrown in there but
you gotta catch it that when she finds
that skinned water buffalo we know
that's not the predator who did that
that was human beings the trappers which
speaks a lot about humanity and the
predators we can be because the water
buffalo are non-threatening animals so
it really came full circle in that sense
it's little things like that that made
this film special and little moments
visually too where when she's first
going on the hunt by herself her walking
past all the woman that are in their
usual roles just gathering things
walking the other direction but she's
walking opposite them that visually
spoke so much which was great and just
as a fan of the character of the
predator cool little things we got to
see him actually
making his skull here of the wolf that
was cool because we know he keeps those
as collectibles and i love when we saw
the predator versus the bear it was a
cool way for nauru to first see the
predator but just the fight was pretty
intense and having the bear
just having the predator's blood come
out of his mouth was really sick and it
had a lot of revenant vibes and i love
the scene when the predator attacks the
jerks that are in naaru's tribe
but it seemed a lot like the original
predator sequence where they have guns
but this time they replaced the guns
with bows so i thought that was really
effective and even things that are set
up in the beginning that come full
circle like having a point to the moment
where the dog has his tail caught in the
trap
to have naru eventually get caught by
that same trap later on was brilliant
and i like the brother got a line here
saying if it bleeds we can kill it
that's just a shout out to the first
film directly from the first film that
line and man when the predator has this
big showdown jumping from tree to tree
in this fog that was so cool and him
using the net to devour that guy and
then one he throws a bear trap to the
head and even humor here of the trappers
having to reload their guns because it's
taking place in the olden days i thought
was actually great and it was sick what
they did with this predator because he
has this awesome shield it kind of
actually felt like wonder woman a bit
that sequence in the fog when he's using
it but like i said it switched things up
and it was brutal they didn't get soft
with the predator and they didn't wait
too long to have him doing these awesome
brutal kills that's what we want to see
and i thought they were all creative and
excellent and it was nice that the
brother wasn't just thrown away and made
a jerk like he had his faults too but he
ended up giving great guidance to his
sister in the end and learning himself
and
saving the dog in the end and goes out
of champ which was awesome and we get a
great final payoff scene with nauru vs
predator and her learning all these
smart ways about the predator how to
stop him and killing him in a smart way
not just some easy way of strength it
was of
wits and brilliance and
i love she got this big victory cry at
the end when she beat him as we all felt
it was cool they got the dog involved
too the dog was a great side character
for nauru and it was a great performance
by amber mid thunder you're seeing a
star in the making here so it's actually
just something that if you're looking at
a film that's this
suspenseful and intense and is simple
but not simple meaning there's a lot of
themes here and it kept me invested the
whole time but you're also getting great
action here everything is creative and
thought outside the box you can tell
there's a lot of work put into this and
the beautiful visuals the environment
the setting it was in i couldn't have
imagined a better case scenario for this
film that it was just a great prequel to
a franchise that's really been dead in
the water so i'm really impressed this
is the shocker of the year for me how
good this was
and i
really am just
appalled that they didn't release this
in theaters it's a head scratcher that
they just put this straight to hulu i
would have loved to watch this in
theaters and i think it would have done
really well because of the praise it's
getting from critics and fans and that
it's still part of a franchise people
know and are familiar with so i think it
would have done good so it's strange it
didn't release it in theaters but i hope
people keep talking about and watch this
this is one of the best
just thriller survivor films i've seen
in a long time i'm giving this one a 9.2
i think it's even better than the
original that's not recency bias just
watching them back to back this is a
better film hands down it doesn't have
any cheesiness here it's great acting
great action great themes and again
everything's serving a purpose with a
pace that moves brisk and doesn't feel
slow at all so and again great visuals
too so i think it just justifies
existence and even more and to top the
original in my eyes is just amazing i am
so shocked how good this film was so i'm
excited and it gets me hyped again for
future films that might be in this
franchise with a predator and we can
stay with this character of nauru and
have new threats of different predators
and kind of maybe lead into the original
predator film i'm excited to see where
they go with this and even they hinted
at predator 2 here with the gun at the
end that we saw in that film here at the
end so really you know they got an idea
too of kind of connecting to original
films eventually but i hope they make
more i haven't said that
again surprise of the year for me and i
absolutely love this film let me know
you thought though love to hear your
thoughts i read every comment try to
respond as many as they can please make
sure to subscribe to miss one of my
reviews i do tv reviews as well and
celebrity interviews it helps me in so
many ways you have no idea just
subscribing and if you love what i do
here you can remember today or you can
just give a one time tip down below if
you hit the button that says thanks it
will help me in so many ways and if you
come remember you get perks as well and
please follow me at steve barley show on
twitter instagram and tick tock for more
of me and i'll see you next time